Talking about traits like Huntington's disease that's
caused by replication errors is just depressing.
>> It is depressing, but not all replication
errors have to be so harmful. Actually, some
replication errors can be kind of good long-term,
and they actually duplicate whole segments of DNA. >
So, are you talking about duplicating a whole
gene? Sure. sometimes a whole segment of DNA
gets duplicated where gene is involved and the
net effect is that an individual has an extra
copy of the gene.
>> But why is that a good thing?
>> Well, you can think about it as a
new source of material for evolution to act on.
>> So the extra copy, one can just
have a mutation and have a whole new function?
>> Sure. That's exactly what happened with
our beta globin genes. Through a process known
as duplication and divergence, an ancestral globin gene
was duplicated several times, and each of the
copies mutated slightly to have a different
ability and expression pattern. Now, each of these
globin genes is important in oxygen binding, and
only expressed at different stages of human development.
>> So, in this case, the replication error
caused something that was overall a positive thing.
>> Yeah, over time, that's exactly what happened.